BUT FIRST, SELLING DEFEATISM.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
"ANGLE"."
NOW, FDR, DURING THE DEPTHS OF
THE GREAT DEPRESSION, AND HIS
FIRST INAUGURAL ADDRESS, TOLD IN
COUNTRY WE HAVE NOTHING TO FEAR
BUT FEAR ITSELF.
THOSE IMMORTAL WORDS WERE MEANT
TO INSTILL CONFIDENCE, NOT
PANIC, TO CONVEY STRENGTH, NOT
WEAKNESS.
WINSTON CHURCHILL DURING THE
WORST OF THE BLITZ ON LONDON
WENT ON RADIO NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
TO BOOST THE SPIRITS OF HIS
PEOPLE AS THE BRUTALLY TRIED TO
SUBMISSION.
NOW, BOTH MEN UNDERSTOOD THAT
PROJECTING FEAR OR WORRY ONTO A
BELEAGUERED PEOPLE IS DANGEROUS.
IN FACT, WHEN A FREE PEOPLE
BEGIN TO DOUBT THEIR OWN
SURVIVAL, WELL, THAT IS WHEN
THEY NEED OPTIMISTIC, UNSHAKABLE
LEADERS THE MOST.
FALLING INTO SELF OR DWELLING ON
THE WORST ASPECTS OF OUR PAST OR
PRESENT ONLY BREEDS
SELF-LOATHING, DEFEATISM, AND
DESPAIR.
AND ULTIMATELY DISASTER.
AND THIS IS PRECISELY THE
MIND-SET TODAY’S DEMOCRATS HAVE
ADOPTED.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS MEDIA HAVE
BECOME MASTERS OF ANTI-AMERICAN
PROPAGANDA.
THEY BELIEVE WE LIVE IN A WICKED
WICKED COUNTRY THAT DESERVES
SUFFERING, PUNISHMENT, AND PAIN.
>> AND WHAT IT DID, THOUGH, IT
ALSO EXPOSED THAT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN PAYING ENOUGH ATTENTION TO
THE UNDERLYING RACISM THAT IS
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN THE
UNITED STATES, STILL EXISTS, HAS
EXISTED FOR 400 YEARS.
AND SO, WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS, WE
END UP IN A CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE
YOU HAD HERE IN KENOSHA.
>> Laura: NOW, JUSTIFYING THE
RIOTS WHILE CONDEMNING THE
VIOLENCE, YEAH, THAT’S REALLY
NICE.
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION FOR BIDEN,
AND THAT THESE
PSEUDO-JOURNALISTS WILL NOT ASK,
IS THIS: SIR, HOW COULD A
SYSTEMATICALLY RACIST COUNTRY
ELECT AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PRESIDENT NOT ONCE, BUT TWICE?
HAS BIDEN FORGOTTEN HIS OWN
RESUME?
AND HERE IS ANOTHER QUESTION:
WHAT WAS JOE BIDEN DOING FOR THE
LAST 47 YEARS?
HOW MANY TIMES HAS BIDEN TALKED
ABOUT WHAT A GREAT COUNTRY WE
HAVE AND WHAT A GREAT PEOPLE WE
ARE?
WAS THAT ALL A LIE, OR IS HE
LYING NOW?
IS HE SMEARING THIS COUNTRY AND
250 YEARS OF AMERICAN HISTORY IN
A CYNICAL ATTEMPT TO WIN
MINORITY VOTES?
WELL, ONE THING IS FOR SURE, HIS
PROTECTORS IN THE MEDIA WON’T
TRY TO FIND OUT.
WHATEVER BIDEN’S MOTIVATION
HERE, WHATEVER IT MIGHT BECOME
HIS WORDS ARE DOING GREAT HARM.
HIS MOST ARDENT SUPPORTERS NOW
OPENLY QUESTION WHETHER AMERICA
WAS ALL ITS WHITE PRIVILEGE
WILL OR EVEN SHOULD SURVIVE.
I JUST PUBLISHED A "NEW YORKER"
PIECE CALLED "THE "THE AMERICAN
MYTH," IT FEELS LIKE THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR NATION HAS
DEEPENING CRACKS, POSSIBLY TOO
MANY TO REPAIR ANY TIME SOON, OR
PERHAPS AT ALL.
THE ATTEMPT TO RECKON WITH OUR
UNJUST PAST HAS PRODUCED MORE
QUESTIONS AND NEW DIVISIONS
ABOUT OUR FUTURE.
WELL, THE FACT IS THE HARD
LEFT -- THAT IS THE HARD LEFT,
GAVE UP ON AMERICA DECADES AGO.
THEY NEVER FORGAVE AMERICANS FOR
ELECTING REAGAN.
AND DISGUSTED WITH THIS COUNTRY,
THEY DECIDED TO POISON ITS
FUTURE.
THEY TOOK OVER THE UNIVERSITIES
AND BEGAN THE SLOW BUT STEADY
PROCESS OF INDOCTRINATING OUR
KIDS TO DESPISE THE
UNITED STATES, TURNING THEIR
MINDS AGAINST OUR HISTORY, OUR
CONSTITUTION, AND OUR
TRADITIONS.
NOW, THIS SORT OF THING WAS
GOING ON WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE,
BUT IT’S GOTTEN MUCH WORSE SINCE
THEN.
OVER THE LAST 35-40 YEARS,
GENERATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SPOON-FED ALL MANNER OF
ANTI-AMERICAN POISON, AND THESE
EFFORTS, WELL, THEY PAID OFF FOR
THE LEFT.
ALL OVER THE BLUE STATES, WE SEE
UNGRATEFUL BRATS ROAMING THE
STREETS IN THEIR ANTIFA COSTUMES
STRAIGHT OUT OF CENTRAL CASTING,
BURNING GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS,
AND EVEN TERRORIZING INNOCENT
AMERICANS.
IT IS A COMBINATION OF IGNORANCE
AND RAGEEND.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY THAT BIDEN
JOINED IN THE EARLY 1970s,
BACK THEN, IT STILL HAD SOME
SENSE.
BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW,
BELIEVED ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION WAS
A PROBLEM.
HECK COME ALMOST 40 YEARS LATER,
BARACK OBAMA WENT TO GREAT
PAINS, REMEMBER, TO DISTANCE
HIMSELF FROM THE HATEFUL
ANTI-AMERICAN RHETORIC OF HIS
MENTOR, JEREMIAH "U.S. OF KK"
RIGHT.
DONALD TRUMP CAME ALONG AND
DEMOCRATS COLLECTIVELY LOST
THEIR MINDS, AND TRUMP, THEY MET
THEIR MATCH, THEY MET SOMEBODY
WHO WAS ON REPLANTED UNREPENTANC
AMERICA.
>> THEY GO AFTER ME BECAUSE I AM
FIGHTING FOR YOU.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS COULD NOT
RISK HIM WINNING AGAIN, SO THEY
THREW IN WITH THE HATE-AMERICA
CROWD, HOPING TO RIDE THE WAVE
OF CIVIL UNREST AFTER GEORGE
FLOYD TO VICTORY IN NOVEMBER.
WELL, THAT WAS WICKED, AND IT
WAS SELFISH.
IT WAS ALSO A HUGE POLITICAL
MISTAKE.
TWO MONTHS INTO THE CHAOS, BIDEN
SCRAMBLED TO COME OUT AND TRY TO
CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE, BUT THE
DAMAGE IS ALREADY DONE.
HE HAS NOW TIED HIS POLITICAL
FORTUNES TO THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN
UP ON AMERICA.
HE HAS STOPPED TRYING TO PUT
FORWARD ANY SERIOUS PROPOSALS
THAT WE KNOW WOULD MAKE LIFE
REALLY BETTER FOR MOST
AMERICANS.
BECAUSE WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER FOR A BUNCH
OF RACISTS?
HE CERTAINLY HAS NO INTENTIONS
OF MAINTAINING AMERICAN POWER,
BECAUSE WHY WOULD YOU WANT A
RACIST COUNTRY TO HAVE ANY
POWER?
WHILE HE IS LEFT WITH, IN FACT,
ARE THE SCRAPS OF MANUFACTURED
SCANDALS THAT THE MEDIA WILL
TOSS OUT FROM NOW UNTIL THE
ELECTION.
WELL, YESTERDAY, WE DEBUNKED
"THE ATLANTIC"’S SMEARS ABOUT
HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP CRITICIZED
OUR TROOPS.
TODAY, AS IF RIGHT ON CUE, THE
PRESS MOVED RIGHT ALONG,
FULMINATING ABOUT BOB WOODWARD’S
NEW BOOK.
TODAY’S BIG CLAIM WAS TRUMP
ALLEGEDLY DOWNPLAYED THE
CORONAVIRUS IN PUBLIC WHILE
PRIVATELY TELLING WOODWARD THAT
IT WAS MUCH MORE DEADLY THAN THE
FLU.
WELL, BIDEN’S FAUX ANGER QUICKLY
FOLLOWED.
>> HE LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHEN HE KNOWINGLY AND WILLINGLY
LIED ABOUT THE THREAT OF CLOSING
THE COUNTRY FOR MONTHS, HE KNEW
HOW DANGEROUS IT WAS.
AND WHILE THIS DEADLY DISEASE
RIPPED THROUGH OUR NATION, HE
FAILED TO DO HIS JOB ON PURPOSE.
>> Laura: AGAIN, THIS IS
NONSENSE.
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THIS HAD
ON TODAY.
>> IT’S JUST ANOTHER POLITICAL
HIT JOB, BUT WHETHER IT WAS
WOODWARD OR ANYBODY ELSE, YOU
CANNOT SHOW A SENSE OF PANIC, OR
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE BIGGER
PROBLEMS THAN YOU’VE EVER HAD
BEFORE.
>> Laura: AND BY THE WAY, HE
SAID AS MUCH AT THE END
OF MARCH, WE WILL GET YOU THAT
ANY MINUTE.
DR. FAUCI, NORMALLY TREATED AS
GOSPEL BY THE TRUMP-HATING
MEDIA, HE DIRECTLY REFUTED THE
MEDIA’S ANTI-TRUMP NARRATIVE.
>> I DIDN’T REALLY SEE ANY
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN WHAT HE
TOLD US AND WHAT WE TOLD HIM AND
WHAT HE ULTIMATELY CAME OUT
PUBLICLY AND SAID.
>> SO DID YOU GET A SENSE THAT
HE WAS OR WASN’T PLAYING THIS
DOWN?
>> NO.
NO, NO, I DIDN’T.
I DIDN’T GET A SENSE HE WAS
DISTORTING ANYTHING.
>> Laura: WHOOPS.
SUDDENLY, FAUCI IS NOT QUOTED
ANY MORE.
AS FOR JOE BIDEN, HE IS THE ONE
WHO WAS DOWNPLAYING THE VIRUS.
HE CRITICIZED TRUMPS CHINA
TRAVEL BAN AND WAS CAMPAIGNING
AT EVENTS INTO MARCH.
THE REALITY IS BIDEN FROM HIS
TEAM, AND HIS SUPPORTERS FROM
ALL OF THEM IN THE PRESS, THEY
HAVE GIVEN UP ON A COUNTRY THAT
YOU LOVE, AND INSTEAD OF
RESPECTING THE ACTUAL
DATA AND DEFENDING OUR
CONSTITUTIONALLY GUARANTEED
FREEDOMS, TEAM BIDEN, THEY WANT
TO LOCK AMERICA DOWN FOR MONTHS.
OF COURSE, THERE IS AN
EXCEPTION.
IF YOU WANT TO RIOT AGAINST
TRUMP, YOU ARE OKAY.
DON’T THINK ABOUT GOING TO
CHURCH, THOUGH, OR HAVING ANY
FUN.
TALK ABOUT DEFEATIST, LET ALONE
STUPID AND DISRUPTIVE.
AND BY CONTRAST, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS AN INFORMED OPTIMIST.
HE WANTS US TO WASH OUR HANDS,
BE SMART, IF YOU WANT TO WEAR A
MASK, WEAR A MASK FROM AND
CARRY-ON.
OF COURSE, BOB WOODWARD WOULD
NEVER PUT ANY OF THAT IN A BOOK.
WE’VE BEEN TELLING YOU SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE NO POSITIVE
PLATFORM TO OFFER, THEY DON’T
BELIEVE THINGS WILL EVER REALLY
GET BETTER IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY NEVER LIKED THIS COUNTRY
MUCH TO BEGIN WITH, AND NOW,
THEY’VE GIVEN UP ON IT TOTALLY.
SO THE ONLY WAY THEY CONVINCE
AMERICANS TO VOTE FOR BIDEN IS
TO ACCEPT LESS.
EXPECT A FULLBORE EFFORT OVER
THE NEXT TWO MONTHS TO
DEMORALIZE YOU, DEMORALIZE TRUMP
VOTERS.
THEY WANT YOU TO ACCEPT DEFEAT
BEFORE A SINGLE VOTE IS COUNTED.
AND THEY ARE USING BIG TECH
BILLIONAIRES TO RESET THE
NARRATIVE.
>> THERE IS NOTHING ILLEGITIMATE
ABOUT THIS ELECTION, TAKING
ADDITIONAL DAYS OR EVEN WEEKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE VOTES
ARE COUNTED.
IN FACT, THAT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
LEGITIMATE AND FAIR ELECTION.
>> Laura: OKAY, THAT’S JUST
CREEPY.
WE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO VOTE IN
PERSON DURING EVERY OTHER MAJOR
AMERICAN CRISIS, SO WHY NOT NOW,
MARK?
BECAUSE TRUMP’S PRESIDENT,
THAT’S WHY!
THE LEFT IS ENGAGED IN AN
ALL-OUT EFFORT TO DEPRESS AND
SUPPRESS THE PRO-TRUMP VOTE.
MEANWHILE, SWAMPING US WITH
MAIL-IN VOTES.
SO FAR, THESE EFFORTS HAVE NOT
WORKED.
WE ARE STILL FIGHTING FOR OUR
COUNTRY, AND THE AMERICA FIRST
POPULIST COALITION SUPPORTING
DONALD TRUMP, WE ARE OPTIMISTIC,
AND MOST AMERICANS ARE JUST
HARDWORKING PEOPLE FEAR WHAT
THEY WANT TO LIVE IN SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
THEY HAVEN’T THROWN IN THE TOWEL
AND I WOULD GUARANTEE OF LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS, AND THEY ARE NOT ABOU